rated M for Mature
this time we're releasing with
multiplayer straight from the box this
isn't an air door north of Europe I
later all this stuff is is available now
and you know having a multiplayer
community that can form from day one so
important and we've made a couple
revisions there to improve the
experience so rather than camping the
whole time we've actually got a
calculated distribution of ammo through
the environments so as you're starting
to run low on ammo that wolf force you
can move on also made a call there to
actually introduce our relocation into
the multiplayer so what that means is if
you're looking for a bit of a bonus to
your standard kills you can relocate and
then trigger a multiplier for the next
kills that you make co-op is a pretty
major part of the sniper experience and
we allow every single mission to be
taken on with a friend which which is
quite cool some of the units are
actually better taken down with a friend
so a lot of the tanks of their weak
spots at the back what that means is
you'll need to get one of your friends
to behave as bait while the other ones
flanking from the back of the tank to
try and shoot that weak spot and we've
got such a versatile suite of units to
throw at the player so they'll be taking
on tanks as well as snipers in addition
to the standard infantry which you're
going to be coming you know in a [ __ ]
like fashion towards a player location
we've got some bespoke AI which actually
governs their behavior as they're
filtering into the play of location
hunting and down in the overwatch mode
we've made some revisions there as well
so we allow the sniper to actually
reconvene with the operative at times
and then they can sort of assess the lay
of the land together before the sniper
goes off to his own position and then
the operative between opposite go in and
get sort of his hands dirty and take out
some of the targets while the slightest
sort of shooting over from above
well the great part of their weapon
customization is you can actually take
those customizations into the single
player all the multiplayer experience if
you've customized a sweet rifle on the
single-player campaign you want to use
that in multiplayer you're more than
welcome to but you need to be careful
because if you get killed and drop that
rifle then the enemy will be able to go
in and pick up that off your body and
use it for the remainder of that round
but all the XP that you accrue during
multiplayer can also be used to
basically get access to all the wicked
weapons traps and items for a single
player as well